(ethereal music)
- [Narrator] 150 feet underground
in 30 million year old caves
an unforgettable sight
glitters in the dark.
The Waitomo Glowworm Caves in New Zealand
are home to about 30,000
endemic Arachnocampa luminosa glowworms.
They spend their days spinning
silk nests from the ceilings
and then lowering
threads to fish for prey,
much like a spider.
The luminescent bead-like
strings are spell binding.
The glowworms use light to attract prey
and burn off waste.
The glow is created by a
combination of chemicals
given off by the glowworm
and the oxygen in the air.
The caves are ideal for the worms
as they need a dark, damp location
where their light can be seen.
The Waitomo Caves they call home
are named after the Maori words wai,
which means water,
and tomo which means hole or shaft.
And although they live deep underground,
the journey to see them is
never one to disappoint.